[Music]
the products and places
are real
but in China they're increasingly being
promoted by virtual humans
as digital technology develops more and
more social media influences and
entertainers are being replaced by these
computer-generated characters
one research firm predicts the market
could be worth 42 billion dollars by
2030 in China alone it's a trend this
company is capitalizing on
these men and women each have their own
personality and backstory for example
one is into popular music there is a
girl next door type a more aloof fashion
blogger and another who is into new
technology
they also have their own fan
but unlike real
real people they don't Tire age or get
into trouble celebrity scandals such as
pop star Chris Wu's rape conviction have
forced Brands to rethink their marketing
strategy there's loads of advantages
right so the first one is you have
absolute control of what this person
does in and outside of your grand comms
so a virtual character ain't gonna go
commit a crime analysts say Chinese
consumers who adapt relatively quickly
to new technologies are more accepting
of virtual humans developers say the key
is to create a virtual human which is as
human-like as possible that allows
consumers to feel a sense of connection
and even intimacy with the character so
wearing this suit will allow my
movements and even my voice to be
programmed into that character
while many are controlled by teams of
people advances in artificial
intelligence means some are taking on
wider roles such as sign language
interpreters
and Newsreaders
Studies have shown this has led to fewer
work opportunities in an already tight
job market but there are also other
concerns you're engaging with influencer
as a as a nice person
um but your your sort of uh
disconnecting your mind from recognizing
actually this person is really just a
complete fabrication of a big corporate
innovator Todd young believes in the
future everyone will have a
computer-generated version of themselves
and that virtual humans are just the
first step Katrina you I'll just ear up
Beijing